il est 20h voici le résultat de ce
premier tour en tête ce soir Emmanuel
Macron devant Marine Le Pen même face à
face qu'en 2017 mais un score imprévu
pour le troisième homme Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et surtout Valérie Pécresse
finalement en dessous de la barre des
cinq pour cent
et Pilogue d'une drôle de campagne
presque inexistante entre fin de crise
sanitaire et guerre en Ukraine
au milieu de Français soucieux
ou indifférent
[Musique]
et Le Pen
la même truc il parle pas de en fait il
parle pas de problème le vrai problème
de la population aucun candidat me plaît
donc je ne pose la question est-ce que
je vais voter j'ai toujours été voté
compte à rebours des 20 derniers jours
avant le premier tour au plus près de
quatre députés
ultra impliqués
[Musique]
voyage au cœur d'une France où ces
quatre députés on devrait à faire voter
[Musique]
Vittel pour la Journée mondiale de l'eau
une centaine de militants pour la
planète veulent dénoncer l'entreprise
Nestlé qui puisse dans les nappes
phréatiques pour sa marque vitesse
[Musique]
Mathilde panot vient de parcourir 350 km
pour en être l'eau c'est son dossier
bien décidé à capitaliser sur le travail
des députés à des filles durant 5 ans
rappelez que le programme de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est rouge
mais aussi vert
[Musique]
c'est une bataille qu'on a qu'on a mené
qui mène beaucoup à cœur que j'avais
mené notamment dans le cadre de la
commission d'enquête que je présidais
sur la question de l'eau
objectif de la journée montrer que
l'équipe de Jean-Luc Mélenchon travaille
les dossiers vous savez que depuis 2020
on peut spéculer sur l'eau en bourse en
Californie parler de fonds pour dire
qu'il y a une alternative à Emmanuel
Macron
l'idée d'aujourd'hui c'est pas de faire
un peu de la politique aille c'est
vraiment de donner du soutien à ces
lutte là et de dire que tout ça est issu
de choix politique et qu'on pourrait
faire toute autrement dans notre pays
auprès de l'électorat d'activistes du
climat son candidat a marqué des points
ce jour-là il est à 14% d'intention de
vote dans les sondages en troisième
position quand Yannick Jadot peine à 5%
[Musique]
l'eau est un bien commun l'air est à
bien commun les sols sont des biens
communs à nous de les protéger et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et le candidat qui
pourra nous aider à justement à protéger
nos ressources notamment les ressources
en eau
mais au moins qu'il aille au deuxième
tour parce que moi il y aura un départ
de fond sur les conceptions que les gens
ont parce qu'en fait c'est un problème
qui a été construit en groupe c'est pas
c'est pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Michel 77 ans est une retraité engagée
mais le candidat Mélenchon reste trop
clivant selon elle
trop excessif
l'abstention promet d'être forte les
indécis nombreux faire campagne c’est
aller chercher les déçus de la politique
le second tour ne paraît pas si
inaccessible vous avez quand vous avez
10 millions de personnes sous le seuil
de pauvreté 8 millions de personnes qui
ont besoin de l'aide alimentaire que
vous avez 12 millions de personnes qui
ont froid chez elle
il y a une majorité sociale du pays qui
a quand même envie de rompre avec ce
système là et alors qu'est-ce qui manque
bon bah de briser ce petit truc de
résignation de toute façon rien ne
changera jamais mais en fait oui tout
peut changer avec cette élection
présidentielle voilà c'est ça qu'on leur
dit aux gens la députée ne ménage pas
ses efforts ah je suis désolé mais j'ai
froid
dans quelques jours Mathilde panot sera
aux Antilles pour convaincre les
électeurs
ultramarins
posent dans la campagne le temps d'une
journée les députés sont obligés de
revenir à Paris le président ukrainien
va leur adresser un message pour savoir
s'adapter la situation c'est un moment
important la guerre
la guerre donne de la gravité à
l'élection présidentielle
des Français sont inquiets il y en a une
inquiétude sur les conséquences de cette
guerre pour eux sur leur pouvoir d'achat
on le voit avec le prix à la pompe des
carburants notamment puis il y a des
conséquences aussi géopolitiques
monsieur le Président de l'Ukraine vous
avez la parole
madame monsieur les parlementaires les
élus de Paris le peuple français je
voudrais poser une question comment
arrêter cette guerre
face à l'impuissance des pays
occidentaux les Français paraissent
davantage sidérés par les images de
guerre
qu'intéressées par l'élection
présidentielle on doit faire campagne
malgré tout parce qu'on a un projet
présidentiel à présenter pour les 5 ans
à venir et il faut qu'on puisse parler
aux françaises et aux Français de ce
qu'on veut leur proposer et en même
temps faut qu'on reste sobre et qu'on
soit dans l'écoute parce qu'ils sont
quand même inquiets de la situation
comment vous allez ce soir et comment
vous abordez ces 15 derniers jours de
campagne en ayant le covid écoutez
aujourd'hui tout tout va à peu près bien
sauf que je m'entends en écho dans mon
oreille donc c'est très très compliqué
compliqué la campagne de Valérie
Pécresse l'aide de plus en plus chaque
jour
[Musique]
et sur le terrain Damien Abate se démène
pour convaincre les électeurs de droite
de rester fidèles aux parties ce jour-là
le député sillonne sa circonscription la
quatrième de l'un ici c'est plus la
droite de conviction
ça joue entre entre nous Le Pen et
Zemmour globalement
les sondages sont mauvais pour sa
championne elle serait en quatrième voir
en cinquième position au premier tour
le soir même au Salon des Vins d'Oyonnax
on ne lui parle que de ça dans une
ambiance potache et pleine de
sous-entendus
[Rires]
du champagne
le parti est pétrifié le peuple de
droite déboussolé par une campagne qui
prend des allures de fiasco mais comment
ça se fait avec
[Musique]
mais après le reste
les militants s'interrogent beaucoup sur
le second tour quitte à refaire le match
des primaires
dans un
Macron
j'aimerais bien voter deux fois le même
candidate j'aimerais bien voter deux
fois Pégase ça veut dire que la deuxième
tour
mais le problème c'est que moi je pense
que c'est la seule qui peut battre
Macron
du Bertrand tu sais est-ce que vous avez
réussi à le convaincre de vos
ça je suis pas sûr mais par contre je
pense que votre rapport au législative
à 15 jours du premier tour le président
du groupe LR à l'Assemblée nationale
pratique la méthode Coué
hésitent même dans vos votre électorat à
vous quoi ça a l'air oui mais c'est
plutôt bon signe ça veut dire que il y
en a beaucoup aussi qui voyez qui sont
pas comptabilisés dans les sondages et
qui disent finalement dernier moment
votre apk parce qu'on est de la famille
de la droite républicaine parce que on
veut un gouvernement de droite parce
qu'on veut une président de droite comme
on voit que c'est possible il faut
expliquer faire la pédagogie prendre du
temps mais moi je pense que rien est
impossible
[Musique]
depuis des semaines Marine Le Pen mène
une campagne presque apaisée sans heurt
niveau 6
la radicalité d'Eric Zemmour a adoucit
son image finalement l'ancien polémiste
s'est révélé être plus comète que ton
pet
Sébastien Chenu Martel que Marine Le Pen
à la stature d'une femme d'Etat une
phrase qui a tiré notre attention ce
matin c'est dans le Journal du Dimanche
Marine Le Pen dit si je suis battu a
priori je ne me représenterai pas est-ce
que c'est la dernière chance de la
dynastie Le Pen fnrn vous savez je crois
que Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui elle est
prête et d'ailleurs il y a quelque chose
de très important je pense qu'il faut
prendre en considération c'est et on le
voit les semaines passant si le peuple
vote alors le peuple va gagner et si les
Français vont voter si le peuple
français va voter Marine Le Pen va être
présente de la République
le peuple a perdu elle elle considère
que aujourd'hui il est possible aussi de
perdre mais je crois qu'en réalité elle
n'a jamais été aussi proche de la
victoire il n'a jamais été aussi prête à
gouverner
Albi dans le Tarn
Marie-Christine Verdier joue classe
privilégie la proximité la bonne vieille
méthode des marcheurs le porte-à-porte à
l'opposé de son candidat un président
qui s'est tenu hors de porter
d'engueulade selon l'expression
consacrée
bonjour mademoiselle je suis
Marie-Christine Verdier du Tarn quel âge
vous avez à 19 ans vous allez voter
peut-être pour la première fois oui
est-ce que vous savez quand est-ce qu'on
vote quand est-ce que c'est le premier
tour
c'est dans deux semaines
incroyable d'autres problèmes qui sont
je trouve majeurs en ce moment et du
coup on n'a pas vraiment envie de penser
politique on a envie de penser ce qu'on
peut faire par rapport à la guerre par
rapport à la guerre d'accord merci
beaucoup au revoir
un seul mot d'ordre ne pas céder à
l'excès de confiance même si Emmanuel
Macron est donnée favori dans les
sondages tous les matins quand je me
lève c'est de dire que rien n'est fait
le soir quand je me couche c'est de dire
que rien n'est fait et donc être sur le
terrain être mobilisé être à l'écoute
parce qu'il faut comprendre aussi
pourquoi et convaincre d'aller voter ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il faut
toujours rappeler que Marine Le Pen
Marine Le Pen pardon c'est l'extrême
droite
défendre un candidat mobilisé sur la
scène européenne et mondiale
bonjour monsieur c'est un atout majeur
de crédibilité je reconnais que Emmanuel
Macron a
le plan sur international surtout il
représente bien
la France
vous pourrez regarder ce qu'on propose
pour les 5 années à venir y compris pour
les seniors
je suis Marie-Christine verdigou classe
mais très vite les vieux dossiers
ressurgissent je ne vais pas voter pour
Monsieur Macron d'accord il y a des
mesures par exemple quand il a supprimé
les 5 euros à l'APL ça c'était au tout
début au tout début
ça c'était quelque chose qui m'avait
choqué vous hésitez à voter pour qui
sans les verres
parce que pour ça je pense qu'il a fait
passer
il faut mettre le turbo maintenant alors
parce que on va dans le mur et et
bien sûr on n'est pas allé assez loin il
faut aller plus loin je me permets quand
même de vous donner le projet vous le
lirez quand même vous regarderez ce
qu'on veut faire sur l'écologie puisque
c'est ce ah non ne me faites pas plaisir
si vous devez pas le lire je le regarde
Vitry-sur-Seine le temps a beau être
morose Mathilde panot il met du coeur
bonjour Alex
avril Jean-Luc Mélenchon bonne journée
bonjour élection présidentielle la
semaine prochaine si vous avez envie de
se venir ce soir on fait un meeting à
Ivry
voilà moi je suis député moi je suis
député avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon voilà et
ben super si vous avez envie on va
parler du programme
[Musique]
en tout cas
elle souhaite mobiliser les
abstentionnistes des quartiers
populaires Marvin 25 ans va se laisser
convaincre voilà si vous avez le temps
vous êtes bienvenu
sinon il nous propose que la droite vous
avez toujours voter ou des fois vous n'y
allez pas
parce que droite ou gauche pour moi
c'est la même chose ils ont un estomac à
la place du coeur
j'ai mis ça et on va passer on va y
arriver
quand les gens sont en colère ou que
voilà il y a des choses qui qui leur
remuent les tripes du coup après
effectivement c'est du punchlines que
vous pourrez réutiliser pratiquement
toute prête à l'Assemblée nationale
à quelques encablures des tractages pour
des candidats de gauche aux oubliettes
dans les sondages
vous avez votre idée nous on est plutôt
vote efficace c'est sûr qu'il y a au
premier tour de cette élection
présidentielle un vote efficace qui
permet à la fois d'éliminer l'extrême
droite du premier tour et d'avoir un
autre débat que de nouveau un Macron Le
Pen avec les les débarrances qu'on
connaît sur la question migratoire
l'après-midi même à Ivry-sur-Seine comme
trois fois par semaine Mathilde panneaux
se mettent en place pour un meeting mais
avant cela elle s'impose un des
incontournables des insoumis dans la
campagne bonjour à vous toutes et tous
une vidéo pour Facebook Twitter et les
autres
meeting pour soutenir la candidature de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et convertir via ces
canola le point fort de son équipe au
plaisir de vous
y voir à 70 ans Jean-Luc Mélenchon et le
candidat au 2 millions d'abonnés sur Tik
Tok le réseau des jeunes
c'est des moyens de communication pour
nous qui sont assez fabuleux parce que
quand vous avez une vidéo comme on en
fait régulièrement où vous avez un
million de million voire 3 millions de
vues c'est faut imaginer l'équivalent en
trac de ce que ça veut dire donc pour
nous c'est des moyens de communication
extrêmement puissants
la campagne s'accélère
un peu partout en France Mathilde panot
comme les autres députés mélenchonistes
remplissent pas moins de 35 par semaine
[Applaudissements]
incomparable dans le pays aucune autre
force politique ne peut sans son
candidat réunir autant de gens
sauf la plus importante pour cette
élection présidentielle ce sont les
peuples qui écrivent l'histoire rien
n'est écrit d'avance vous êtes cette
lueur les amis jusqu'à la victoire
ambiance diamétralement opposé du côté
des macronistes le président candidat
s'offre la plus grande salle d'Europe et
30000 places occupées pour son seul
meeting d'avant premier tour
un spectacle digne d'une star
internationale
pour Marie-Christine Verdier classe
c'est un moment de grâce
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
une parenthèse enchantée dans une
campagne un peu tristoune une façon de
revivifier l'esprit des débuts pour
cette députée
issu du monde de l'entreprise
le mouvement marche c'était Emmanuel
Macron et pour moi c'est toujours
Emmanuel Macron et c'est vrai que c'est
lui que j'ai suivi parce qu'il a pris
des engagements que j'ai cru en Lui j'ai
cru en son programme les cinq ans après
aujourd'hui je suis toujours dans la
même conviction et sans lui je ne sais
pas ce que ça pourrait être en tout cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour le plus grand plaisir de la député
le président candidat renoue avec le et
de droite et de gauche je crois à la
même temps
du jacobinisme et du girondisme
on doit pouvoir y arriver
alors j'assume oui de vous dire qu'il
faudra travailler plus et d'abord
travailler plus longtemps parce que nous
vivons plus vieux et de prévenir que
cette fois-ci l'extrême droite serait
bel et bien aux portes du pouvoir
regardez
du brexit attend d’élection ce qui
paraissait improbable et qui a pu
advenir alors je vous le dis avec
beaucoup de force ce soir je veux la
mobilisation générale la volonté et
l'action
une députée boostée
[Applaudissements]
pour la dernière semaine avant le
premier tour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Denain dans le Nord
un dimanche de brocante avec Marine bon
week-end
marine
la fille déjà Marie de Pen
Sébastien Chenu député du coin à
labourrer le terrain tout le monde le
connaît
merci merci ici c'est la France des
oubliés qui a voté à 40 % pour le FN au
1er tour en 2017 j'espère que dimanche
prochain il sera aussi beau
espérer FN devenu RN qui promet encore
de progresser ici les gens ont été les
premiers impactés par les décisions
politiques qui ont été prises depuis 40
ans ici on a fermé
Usinor ici on a fermé les mines les gens
ont subi la mondialisation en premier
comme ils ont subi en premier ils ont
réagi en premier
en choisissant d'accès sa campagne sur
le pouvoir d'achat plutôt que sur
l'immigration l'équipe le pénis à visé
juste
en fonction de l'inflation il est depuis
on est peut-être un peu sec pourtant
Marine Le Pen vient ici à Bouchin ou
quand elle vient dans d'autres villes
c'est-à-dire dans lequel il y a jamais
une vitrine politique dans lesquelles
les gens ne voient jamais personne
passer c'est toujours dans les grandes
métropoles que les hommes politiques
font des véhicules ont vu hier avec
Emmanuel Macron il oublie toute une
partie de la France et donc toute une
partie des Français
et aujourd'hui on vous attend très
nombreux
va y avoir de l'ambiance ça va être
super et c'est un hologramme après nous
12 métiers on vous attend très nombreux
pour nous donner de la force pour
emmener Jean-Luc Mélenchon au second
tour et avec plein de vidéos
[Applaudissements]
tour de force technologie pour son
dernier meeting avant le premier tour
entouré de Mathilde panot et d'autres
députés le leader insoumis et ses
holographes rassemble 20 000 personnes
par tout en France
avant la fin de la campagne électorale
la France qui se cherche
le peuple qui tâtonne
regarde vers nous
et se dit
voilà la France
voilà celle que nous voulons
[Applaudissements]
à Lyon ce soir-là dernier tour de piste
pour la candidatellaire et une
atmosphère de désolation
Valérie Pécresse ne sera pas au second
tour c'est dans toutes les têtes
Damien Abad s'inquiète même d'un
scénario inattendu
[Musique]
Sarkozy brissort feu semblent abattus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout le monde craint pour l'avenir du
parti les personnalités LR vont-elles
appelées à voter Emmanuel Macron et au
front républicain à l'annonce des
résultats du premier tour
telle est déjà la question discussion
entre Damien Abad et un membre DLR
enage mais ni front républicain
dimanche soir j'attends qu'un mot
respect pour tous mes électeurs je ne
donnerai aucune confiance de votre site
elle n'y est pas
dernier mot de la candidate et un petit
message personnel dans une campagne
annonciatrice d'un cataclysme
probable président de groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale cette campagne qui
devait être celle des débauchages n'a
pas eu lieu et la gamelle macronienne
est restée assez peu rempli alors je le
dis merci Damien bravo
reste à savoir si cette gamelle
macronienne se remplira après le premier
tour
[Musique]
au même moment à Perpignan plus de 3000
personnes l'attendent
cette fois-ci je suis persuadé qu'elle
va gagner oui pourquoi parce que je
enfin je le sens enfin nous les
militants en Haute-Garonne quand on va
sur les marchés à la rencontre des
Français
là on se rend compte que vraiment cette
fois-ci c'est la bonne quoi on est bien
accueilli surtout sur les marchés tout
ça les gens parlent et tout oh c'est
plus comme avant ah non non le Pen
surtout pas le peine non non là ça va
toujours très concentré
Sébastien je suis venu est
particulièrement serein
je pense que Marine Le Pen est prête et
que les gens le sentent parce que de
l'autre côté Emmanuel Macron il a un
bilan et que les gens le ressentent dans
un pays qui a été beaucoup abîmé
beaucoup brutalisé et qui aspire à être
unis à être réuni
ambiance décontractée et même joyeuse
dans la loge de la candidate reine
à quelques minutes de son entrée en
scène Marine Le Pen semble plus sûr
d'elle que jamais
les Français ont pris conscience que on
ne peut pas se permettre cinq années de
plus d'Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce qui a
changé entre 2017 et aujourd'hui en 2022
bah toute a changé tout a changé le pays
d'ailleurs lui-même a changé pas en
mieux et là mais je pense qu'il y a une
sentiment d'urgence pour les militants
le programme du rassemblement national
est perçu comme étant et de droite et de
gauche le parti a repris le mantra de
son principal adversaire et la martelée
toute la campagne
j'ose le dire et je l'assume
en ce qu'il prend totalement contre les
questions du quotidien au premier rang
desquels votre pouvoir d'achat votre
qualité de vie de travail l'école
on recharge encore en énergie avant le
second tour et où on galvanismes
dernier jour de campagne avant le
premier tour Marie-Christine Verdier
joue classe c'est qu'il faut raviver
l'électorat de gauche d'Emmanuel Macron
direction Carmaux la terre de Jaurès
tout un symbole ici les gens n'hésitent
pas à lui dire ce qu'il pense du bilan
du quinquennat
[Musique]
pour moi c'est pas du tout assez social
alors du tout dites moi pourquoi et ça
m'intéresse vraiment parce que vous
voyez on a supprimé la taxe d'habitation
on a baissé les impôts des deux
premières tranches moi j'entends quand
vous dites qu'on est pas social mais
alors c'est quoi ne pas social j'entends
j'entends des tas de gens qui vivent
autour de moi qui disent on entend
parler d'aide on les perçoit pas on a on
a toujours des impôts importants on vit
difficilement ça ne s'améliore pas le
débat sont venimes parfois sur la
tentation du vote Le Pen pour moi si on
met un extrême au pouvoir si on sort de
la démocratie
ils ne sont pas capables eux-mêmes de
choisir ce qu'ils ont à faire quand on a
des candidats qui surfs systématiquement
sur les peurs quand on brandit le
drapeau les immigrés ils sont là ils
vous prennent votre travail ils prennent
toutes les aides ils sont en train de à
sec votre pays vous vous croyez que ça
c'est un discours que on peut
accepterables ils sont assez adultes
pour savoir
je suis persuadé que les gens il faut
arrêter arrêter de les prendre pour les
enfants on verra il y a pas de souci on
verra dimanche je vous souhaite beaucoup
de courage voilà ça c'est vrai ça c'est
une vérité par contre aujourd'hui
deux jours plus tard Emmanuel Macron
arrive en tête avec un million 600 000
voix de plus que la candidate du
rassemblement national
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]